je la comprends dit pour être vacciné il
fallait jusqu'ici est résident d pad ou
travailleurs de santé de plus de 50 ans
à partir d'aujourd'hui la vaccination
est ouverte à toute personne âgée de
plus de 75 ans mais pas seulement elle
continue de monter en régime la semaine
dernière nous avions vacciner plus de
70000 personnes sur un jour donné cette
semaine ce sera encore davantage avec
l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination dans les ehpad
nous aurons largement atteint notre
objectif du million de français vaccinés
d'ici à la fin du mois pour vacciner les
plus de 6 millions de personnes
concernées par cette nouvelle étape
plus de 800 centres comme celui ci ont
été ouverts après le début chaotique de
la campagne de vaccination fin décembre
l'enjeu pour le gouvernement est de
réussir cette nouvelle phase
mais des élus locaux pointe déjà le
manque de vaccins disponibles
nous sommes sur dix mille doses par
semaine en tout cas c'est ce qu'on nous
a indiqués pour les plus de 75 ans si on
restait sur un rythme de 10 mille doses
par semaine il nous faudrait en
huit mois pour arriver à vacciner
uniquement les plus de 75 ans françois
rebsamen maire de dijon et soutien d'
emmanuel macron en 2017 est encore plus
direct
la carence de l'état central dans la
livraison de vaccins kovy 19 pour les
populations de dijon et besançon dépasse
l'entendement nous souhaitons une
information transparente et des
explications sommes-nous en pénurie de
vaccins une question qui se pose depuis
que pfizer biotech a annoncé cette
semaine un réaménagement de son site de
production européens
notre installation de puurs en belgique
connaîtra une réduction temporaire du
nombre de doses délivrées dans la
semaine à venir
nous reviendrons calendrier initial de
livraisons à l'union européenne à partir
de la semaine du 25 janvier avec une
livraison accrue à compter de la semaine
du 15 février
malgré ce retard de fabrication le
gouvernement maintient toujours vouloir
vacciner 15 millions de personnes d'ici
cet été